Chris Hogan here I've spent a lot of
time traveling speaking and talking with
people all around the country a topic
that continues to get me fired up is the
self-made millionaire and their success
story
I've even devoted segments of my
podcasts retire inspired to talking with
these self-made millionaires you're
about to step into the life of someone
who crossed over to millionaire status
on their own term said I've got a PhD in
sales I'm poor hungry and determined I
never even thought about being me in
there my thing was just be a good
provider for my family you don't want to
miss it people this is millionaire I'm
Sam from price flow Alabama
been married for 34 years took my
wonderful wife Jean I work as a real
agent for Remax platinum here in price
cool I also work at high vxp
it's a chemical plant in Decatur we have
12 acres here we bought it as a sage
field and built the house ourselves
little by little we added the barn the
pasture and then the workshop and just
been kind of continuously trying to make
it better just looking back when I
started put money into the 401k and
because of the money that the company
was setting aside for a pension for me
the growth in those where we're at today
we're probably out of net worth of 1.2
maybe even a little bit more maybe 1.3
million my dad growing up he was he kind
of chased a lot of get-rich-quick
schemes and when he died he was still in
debt and I kind of used that as an
example of what not to do I was the
oldest of six kids at home didn't have
the money for college really didn't have
a whole lot of job opportunities so I
went into the Marine Corps stated
electronics on helicopters actually had
a really good career in the Marine Corps
did 20 what did 15 years back to the
duty I retired from the Marine Corps in
2001 actually retired September 1st
tried to go back after 9/11 they
wouldn't let me come back they say if we
need you we know where to find you
about 12 years ago I got to looking at
how it's gonna pay for college for
mobile it's because I did I never had
that opportunity so we didn't go to
school I've always loved sales
I've always loved real estate so I
thought well if I can just get my
license and start selling real estate if
I can sell one house a month I can put
my kids through school without having to
go into debt and that's about time I
started listening to the Dave Ramsey
when I started with selling real estate
I also still worked out at the Klan and
at the time it was VP my job is a salary
job I go in at 6:00 in the morning I get
off at 4:30 in afternoon everybody wants
to see houses at nights and weekends so
that just kind of fell right in line
with it the first three months so I had
my real estate license I sold a million
dollars worth of real estate and now I
average selling about 30 to 35 houses or
properties a year I was able to quickly
both boys through school eight years of
college no debt
I told them if they would make the
grades I'd make the money and that's one
of the drives I've always had
[Music]
the chemical plant was still my bread
and butter
that's where my insurance was paid
that's where my benefits came from so I
started contributing at work I put in
10% of my pay into a 401k every time I
got a pay raise I bumped that up 1% well
I finally got up to where I spent 15
percent into my 401k the company was
matching 7% so that you know it's pretty
good a little nest egg going in and kind
of grew well then when BP sold out I was
over 50 years old I had been with the
company at least 20 years and so they
gave me a my pension they said that we
were eligible for a lump sum I looked at
it and was amazed at how much it had
grown it was a little over two hundred
fifty thousand so I took the lump sum
moved it down to Edward Jones talked to
my broker there and we made some
decisions on how we wanted to invest I
used a lot of Dave's principles on that
and I never really thought about being a
millionaire in fact I didn't even
realize until just recently when
listening to Dave on the radio you know
somebody asked him so well how do you
know when you get to the beat of meeting
their status and he said basically take
your assets add them up you know
subtract out what you owe and that tells
you where you're at and I went back and
looked at my 401k and I looked at the
IRA that I had set up with Edward Jones
and he came out to nine hundred twelve
thousand dollars when I realized that
that was nine hundred twelve thousand I
mean I just kind of floored me now that
I'm there I've decided I'm not gonna
quit working I want to be able to pass
on to my kids and to their kids a little
bit of a legacy and so to do that I'll
continue to work in both jobs
for the next four or five six years but
if I keep putting money into the savings
and keep letting it grow
it'll grow and five years down the road
who knows where I'll be
[Music]
if you make $20,000 a year you make
$40,000 here you make $200,000 here you
can get to that meeting that status if
you want to if you're willing to put a
little bit of money aside and live on
less than you make I'm proof if you
start at 35 you can do it it's just you
have to put a little bit more aside than
then you would have had to if you
started at 19 or 20 you're not going to
just jump in to where I am today but the
biggest thing is you've got to start
somewhere start start putting something
aside a little bit of time you can look
on Dave Ramsey site and find your
endorse local provider you can go there
talk to them about how much do I need to
start putting into a an IRA to get it
started and then just continue to do it
you've got to get started if you don't
start early you've got to get started at
some point I went from $14,000 a year to
now this last year I made $200,000 but I
work two full time jobs to do it you can
keep working at it and you can build $20
a week we spend that on sodas people
spend that on cigarettes if you just
take that little bit of money and stick
it into a savings account when it gets a
little bit bigger you opened your IRA
that grows over time seeing the numbers
that I was sudden it's over a million
dollars net worth my first thing was
okay
what I do now how does that change
things obviously it gives me a chance I
can give a little bit more I can do
things that we'd like to do you enjoy
life because you've worked hard and you
set it aside you have your kids you have
to your family and friends when I start
selling real estate and I was successful
at it
it changed my family tree I grew up poor
yeah I've been there my kids have never
had to know that you know my grandkids
probably will never have
that because working two jobs and being
able to put back and watching my net
worth grow
I can change my family tree from here on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you